education now as higher education in the
U.S in particular is in a sad State and
I've written about it extensively as you
know the Free Speech this notion of of
the secular religion of assuming things
are true and then and then not allowing
anyone to question it that's the worst
part
education should be based on constant
questioning that's why you know that's
why my book is whether it's it's
questions every chapter begins with
questions that's how we move forward and
if you can't question something and
that's happening too often throughout
higher education and a sense of fear
I mean questioning stops when you're
afraid that question and that's that's
and it's that fear that scares me the
most any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
welcome everybody to an exciting episode
of into the impossible with longtime
friend of the show Almost professor of
mine at Case Western Reserve University
uh beloved Communicator of Science and
practicing uh magician and that to me is
the most exciting way to start an
episode Lawrence as you know the
namesake of the institution that I am
the associate director of at UC San
Diego is called the Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination we're going
to be talking about your imagination and
your thoughts on the future but before
we do that we always open every episode
with Arthur in his own voice saying the
following any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic what do you have to say to those
accusations Lawrence
I have to say that you know Arthur
obviously didn't know about real magic
because there's real magic here here in
fact let me pass part of the magic of
the modern world is produced by
technology as you say sufficiently
Advanced it would look like magic for
example here we are talking to one
another looking at each other across the
continent which would have seemed just
impossible a while ago but this is even
better I can pass you here take it for
me I can pass you this invisible deck of
cards we now take that invisible deck of
cards out of the out of the box
and put the box down you can shuffle
them if you want put the box down yeah I
think you dropped the card okay there we
go okay could you um could you now take
it out and hold it up in front of you
and and look at the cards okay look pick
your favorite card
okay now now pick one to the right of it
okay got that now take that one out take
that one out of the deck
turn it around so it's facing the
opposite direction of all the other
cards put it back down close up the deck
and put it back in the box
and hand it to me
okay
and the first thing that's amazing is it
comes back as a real deck which is
really magic okay now what was your card
uh it was of course the four of Clubs
all four of clubs why of course is that
is that your favorite card or yes a
long-term listeners to the podcast no
that's my phone oh okay okay well so
that means there should be I better get
up this way that means let's see I'm
gonna have to hold it up this way there
should be one card here turned over
right yeah okay and it was the four of
clubs you tell me that's true yeah okay
okay let's just let's just look let's
look
can you see it hold on
I don't know what it is but let's just
see unbelievable
ladies and gentlemen that is true magic
that is unparalleled magician at work
undoubtedly you have you are responsible
for pen and teller's success I mean I'm
so grateful that you've taught them I've
taught them everything although I did
one trick with them but but I know it's
embarrassing anyway that's the first
time I've done that on the air so there
we go wow it's an exclusive for your
program it's good to be back with you as
you said I was almost your your
professor but I was almost even better I
was almost your professor's boss because
I was sure yeah that's right you were a
chair
yeah I barely I had the chance to kind
of clean out your office before before
leaving and I'm going back to Case
Western we have a lot of listeners in
Cleveland I'm being honored with a
distinguished alumni award in October so
stay tuned for more details about that
um but uh Lawrence yes you've uh you've
done it again you've written a book that
in my mind is comparable to the
character physical law but updated by
five decades or so and that uh was sort
of a double entender as you French
Canadians might say as far as I
understood it because Feynman was a
character and Lawrence you're a
character too let's be honest okay we
just did Magic first ever live magic
I've known you for not just your con
Converse you know All-Stars that you
wear on stage with with iridescent pink
socks which is uh so so delightful but
you've written a book and as you know on
this show we always open the segment
with what you're never supposed to do
which is to judge a book by its cover
Lawrence
so the edge of knowledge has actually
two covers so we're gonna go twice yeah
a good good choice of fingers okay so
you've got the uh American Edition there
which I read and listened to so I had
the Kindle edition the audio Edition and
the physical Edition thanks to
Lawrence's a munificence but Lawrence
now I ask you to do the following
explain the title The subtitle and the
cover illustration of both editions go
because this just arrives a half an hour
ago at my house so I'm really excited
about it I love it when they arrive it's
always I didn't know that was coming
well explain the title well let me the
the British title is easier to explain
because it comes from a quote from your
favorite politician Donald rumsfelder
yes that's right rummy rummy yeah rummy
you and him just like that I think
um anyway I'm not a big fan of Rummy but
nevertheless you know when someone says
something intelligent I I try not to
cancel people just because you know I
try to listen what they say and uh and
he made this great quote about when
unfortunately in the horrendous invasion
of Iraq which was which I didn't
actually I didn't agree with he argued
that there were things you knew you you
know you knew and there were things you
knew you didn't know and there were some
things you didn't know you didn't know
and of course in that case they did they
thought they knew something they didn't
know but the the idea of the known
unknowns
was um was compelling to me it actually
came in a discussion with my British
publisher because
um
that you know when we when we do science
when you and I do science we
we're basing it on what we we're trying
to explore the unknown based on what we
know and the questions or the things we
know we don't know of course the most
exciting thing in science is the unknown
unknowns okay that would make a very
short book and and and what I wanted to
do I wanted to go past you know I've
written say the universe from nothing I
wanted to take this book and and take
people to the edge literally the edge of
knowledge which is the title of the
American version and the reason that
that's the title of the American version
is I use that term in the book but also
my American Publishers decided that
rummy might be a little too polarizing
and uh and but the idea is twofold first
of all to get some appreciation of the
vast unknown I've got to take people up
to that precipice so it gave me a hook
to bring people to the Forefront of our
understanding of Science in a wide
variety of areas but also to point out
that and this is what's really important
that's why I put it in the very
beginning of the book that saying I
don't know is Central to science it's
what drives science it's it's it people
don't appreciate that it's not being
satisfied being so proud of yourself or
knowing something it's it's the search
for for the unknown and being willing to
sit not only say you don't know but be
willing to be wrong to be willing to say
well this is what I think is going to
happen but it's but then finding
something else in fact celebrating that
because you know the best thing you as
an experimentalist that you could find
is something you didn't expect to find
yeah and I actually brought that up
yesterday in my cosmology class so shout
out to physics 162 class uh I'll get
Lawrence to give a shout out last year
at this time I had Neil deGrasse Tyson
on a podcast and he gave a shout out so
you'll have to wish them good luck in
their midterm terms next week but I was
talking about this guy here do you
recognize this guy Lawrence I have right
here okay there he is camera okay so I
said to him uh there's a proverb in the
talmud which you of course know
backwards and forwards as we talked
about when you Grace when you asked me
on the origins podcast we had a good
rousing discussion just a quick pause to
ask you for a small favor while my thumb
is occupied with old Albert on it yours
is presumably freed up to leave a thumbs
up on this video really helps me a lot
with a good old-fashioned YouTube
algorithm thanks a lot now back to the
video
uh the proverb goes as follows man
should have two pockets and in each note
he should have a different an inch
pocket he should have a different note
in the left pocket he should have a note
that says I am nothing but dust and
Ashes and in the right pocket he should
have another note that says the whole
universe was made for me balancing the
Cilla and charybdis of haughtiness and
ego which drives some of us and humility
which we should be at least aware of and
I brought up Einstein because as you
know this is this is no no education for
you you could you could tell me things
that I have forgot you've forgotten more
than I know okay let's stipulate that
but Einstein in 1919 uh he got wrong in
1915 the gr deflection of the angular uh
apparent trajectory of Light by a factor
of two I think he was rung by a factor
of two and let's nerd out later about
exactly because you you could explain it
to my students better than I could but
uh two years and and then a year or two
later there was an eclipse in Crimea of
all places and he had they had said I'll
add your story in a second it's even
more dramatic than you say okay why
don't you tell it but the point is when
it was finally revealed that Einstein
after the 1919 eclipse of Eddington Fame
that Einstein was right uh the newspaper
asked him they said only 12 men in the
world understand it I love to point that
out that the females in my class get
really pissed off at that for good
reason at the New York Times but that's
no surprise but I said uh in addition
they asked him what would you have done
if you found out that you were wrong and
Einstein said I would feel sorry for the
good Lord because my equations are
correct and yet Lawrence so that's the
that's the arrogance that's the universe
was made for Albert okay but on the
other hand 1929 rolls around there's old
Albert he finds out from Hubble the
cosmological term is no more of course
we know that's a blunder but he calls
that reputably to gamov says it's his
biggest bone how do you balance those
two things first of all embellish the
story as you wish because it's your show
uh but but tell me how do you balance
the need to be humble with the need to
be bold and have Swagger to create Magic
okay wow sure that's an interesting
question okay but I will first add to
your story because yeah it's
um it's important it's really an amazing
accent of history that the luckiest
thing for Albert Einstein not for many
other people was World War One
because the eclipse that they were going
to test his ideas on was 1914. and they
were going out to test it and the war
broke out so they couldn't test the his
ideas and it was during that war that
that he revised his calculations so that
by the time in 1916 when he produced
general relativity at the they could
then at the end of the war test his new
prediction had there not been World War
one they would have tested prediction he
would have gotten it wrong you wouldn't
know who Albert Einstein is and and so
he was very the war was very very good
to him in that sense the first war the
other guys got kidnapped yeah the guys
that got kidnapped not so much right
yeah and so it's it's it's really a
fluke and it was kind of fortunate for
him in the world although I think on the
whole he would have been happier and
probably the rest of the world if World
War One hadn't happened yeah um and you
know I don't know about that other 12
people you know the the story the worst
part of that story was when they asked
Sir Arthur Stanley Eddington who who was
the British person who tried to
interpret Einstein for the British
public and he was an incredible pompous
ass
um about uh you know there are 12 men
who understand Russell you know general
relativity who were the other ones and
he said and then he said who are the
other ones you know because now he was a
pompous ass I don't think he ever did
the the other part with with that
Einstein did it the humility and I think
the point is
that
well I don't want to necessarily talk
about me but I think the Explorer in
general whether it's an Explorer in
science or nature or geology or
geography
is forced into humility because you have
the boldness to go in fact it's where no
one's gone before you know I just did
something with a little shot in her but
but in doing that what you encounter is
a universe or a or a geography that's so
much grander than you ever imagined that
you can't help realizing your own
insignificance so in my mind
yes you need a brashness to be able in
fact it's terrifying it's a we talked
about this before
but there's a you know there's a real
one difference between experimental
physicists and theoretical physicists
is first you actually do something
you've actually built things it actually
just I just you know but
but it was Steve Weinberg who first said
that you know it's incredibly
intimidating to be sitting in your room
at night thinking somehow when you're
writing something down that nature is
actually going to obey what you're
talking about it just seems impossible
and it is and on the few occasions where
it happens that that that's the case
it's just it's just intimidating I mean
I remember
when I first started to think of the
energy of empty space being non-zero it
just and the idea that was would be was
just amazing but so but so I think
there's that combination but some what
that's what's wonderful about science is
it continues to reinforce the notion of
the that that pocket that that piece of
paper in that other pocket just isn't
true the universe isn't made for us we
all we all need to feel that way I think
on a daily basis just to get out of bed
but science reminds us that the that
that that feeling is myopic and we have
to be reminded I I I think it's because
it's so non-intuitive it's so Central to
our being to sense that everything is
made for us and uh and I I think I once
I think I told you this once I I was at
a debate at Oxford on on the question
was everyone is religious and I actually
took the pro side yeah my faith is
colleagues took the other side and I
said well you know if everyone wasn't
religious by Nature we wouldn't need
science in a sense that in the sense
that science is there to can The World
Isn't made for us yeah you've even
written that you know that science
wouldn't exist in its current form had
there not been but for the existence of
religion and I salute you yeah
and we grew out of it but that some of
us you have some of us yeah some of us
are out of it you know some of us uh you
know we all have lacunae in our in our
educations
so what I like uh about this book again
the double entender is reminiscent and
evocative of that great character from
Pasadena Richard Feynman in this case
what it means to me life's Edge is that
um or sorry at the edge of knowledge I'm
I was thinking in the back of my mind
about an interview I just did with Carl
Zimmer which will come out after this
interview about his most recent book
called a life's Edge and we got into
kind of a friendly debate because he
opens his book with a discussion of my
friend Ben Shapiro and uh Ben Shapiro's
discussion about life begins at
conception and of course Carl's like you
he's a he's a liberal leaning you know a
person and uh and of course he's he has
a uh he has a take on it that you know
well if that's true then you know when
every time you shed a skin cell that's
life and are you killing life so I I
think but I brought up the point to him
the edge cases make bad law okay so he
has Edge in his title you have Edge in
your American Title and that's because
the human brain is not configured or
wired for ambiguity that's why you know
we can agree that prob in America at
least you know we can agree that you
know you shouldn't have an anti-tank
weapon but you should have some form of
protection right so the gun rights or
abortion like I don't think many people
should say although my father used to
say you know I believe in abortion up
until the 27th trimester he said that
when I was about nine or ten years old
but but you know abortion between boys
who said it should abortion should be
legal until they're 18 but anyway
exactly that's right uh so uh so anyway
the point being the human mind is not
configured properly for this type of
ambiguity and resolution the five
Explorations that you go into this book
are all ambiguous in their own way you
go into life you get into space you get
into matter and we're going to cover all
those in different levels of detail but
how do you resolve these things uh
Lawrence in your own mind how do you
handle situations where there's not
enough information the human mind tries
to fill it in but it's a Schrodinger
State it's ambiguous the ambiguity of it
is overwhelming how do you personally
handle that as a scientist or just as a
man
well I guess I I mean I think it's
probably psychological I find the
ambiguity in general uh invigorating uh
then because because I guess I've always
felt that not knowing uh even what I'm
going to be doing tomorrow is what one
of the reasons to wake up in the morning
and
that
it it is
it's so refreshing to get to that point
if you're studying science one of the
reasons you know people
I remember I actually dropped first-year
physics and asked to go to secure
because you know I get these inclined
planes and you get all this and and and
what you want to get to is is is well
it's the ideology you want to get to the
point where we you know where not only
is it interesting I know an incline
plane isn't interesting but but where
the answer may not be so obvious
we all love puzzles I do think people
are well we you talked about being
hardwired
um I think actually we are hardwired for
edges visually I think that the visual
field is you can see edges very well but
the phobia yeah but but the the I think
people are hardwired to want to solve
puzzles and I and they're and there's
you can imagine all sorts of
evolutionary reasons for that this the
the teleology the notion that they're
there's you know there's something
behind a mystery it helps you save you
from lines on the Savannah and so you
can imagine that but it's it's that
notion of solving puzzles that makes it
um exciting and I think you know that it
wouldn't if you were doing a jigsaw
puzzle if you imagine unraveling the
world is like a jigsaw puzzle right if
if if it was obvious which piece went
where it wouldn't be fun to do the
puzzle right it's it's conquering and
I'm not good at it but my wife is but
it's conquering that fact that they all
look the same and I'm colorblind so it
makes it even harder but um but so I
think
um
you know I didn't like most books I've
written I really didn't know where I was
going to be going when I wrote it and it
took a while before I I found out what I
wanted to do I didn't even know what the
Topic's really going to be and I but I I
thought what I would try and do was
touch in one way or another
those questions that everyone asks
because what's amazing is that the
Forefront of Science and in all areas
Beyond physics tend to deal with those
questions the basic questions that we
all started asking in the first place
the things that motivate everyone you
are we alone in the universe out of the
universe again without life originate
you know uh what's time I mean and you
know all of can I go backwards can I can
I revisit the mistakes of my youth
either either correct them or or enjoy
them again but uh
um so I think I I found it gratifying to
think about those Central topics because
one of the things I've always tried to
do in in my books is to try to you know
Bridge science and culture and and the
same with care I mean I I'm very honored
by your connection to the character of
physical law which is which fireman's
Masterpiece book based on his I think
messenger lectures at Cornell
um which I saw as a kid and I read the
book and it was it was the fact they
were
that there were open questions that made
it so exciting for me uh and it really I
think you know one always reinvents
one's memories and I talk about that in
some sense in the Consciousness chapter
but but I think I do distinctly remember
when this teacher at this special
science program is on gave me this book
because I look bored
and it's the first book I read where
kind of it was clear to me you know I've
been reading about Einstein I'd read
about all the and but it was now clear
that it wasn't all done and it wasn't
even all done you know by dead white men
200 years ago it was and that notion
that one could participate in the future
and was was really what turned me on and
as you say I I I I I don't have the
presumption that'll happen but I'd like
this to be an invitation for some young
people to say look at these you know
it's amazing what we discovered but it
what what's what's more amazing is
what's yet to be discovered and and not
to be embarrassed that's the other thing
but to celebrate I mean scientists
really do celebrate not knowing it's the
only area
of human inquiry I think we can do that
so well and wouldn't it be a better
world of politicians as well as parents
and teachers uh celebrated not knowing
where will you say I don't know let's
try and figure it out let's try and do a
public policy I don't know if it's going
to work let's see if it works you know
the problem yeah I mean the problem is
another type of game you know uh where
edges come into play or these concepts
of infinite games versus finite games
you know and a finite game I want to win
and politics you know you're it's a
finite game in an infinite game the
object is to keep playing and science I
always say is a is a is an infinite game
but it's comprised of an awful lot of
finite games you know from getting into
graduate school to getting a postdoc to
getting a professorship to getting
tenure day winning the Nobel Prize you
know these are finite games but the
Enterprise of science is never done
somebody said once I mean my father used
to tell me of my late father you know
science is like a battle where the enemy
is infinite but they're always
retreating away from you so you have
this illusion of progress but you also
have this uh true progress that you do
with so let's get into them otherwise
you know I think they're a lot I think I
have to say I'm going to interrupt you
because you know I do that
um but but uh
it's interesting that you say that and
essentially your father said that
because you know in the 1980s and you're
just a baby so you won't remember them
but um 51 year old baby yeah but uh
so I phys physics made this sudden
switch
to the presumption of some people that
we're gonna that would have what was
called The Theory of Everything and
suddenly you know it would all be done
and it's interesting Feynman who never
liked string theory for a variety of
reasons he said it didn't answer any
questions I think one of the reasons he
didn't like it was again a a
driven by his character
he likened the universe should be being
like this onion with an infinite number
of layers and for him you know it didn't
matter if they're an infant on her life
it didn't matter if he never got to the
absolute truth all he wanted to do was
peel back another layer and see the next
layer and understand more tomorrow than
he than he he did today and um and I by
the way I have to you the other thing
you remind me of was a quote at the end
of my book from one of my favorite
science writers and scientists Jacob
brunowski we used to live in La Jolla he
used to live yeah yeah and he was and I
met his daughter but he had already
passed away before I got to know him but
I I uh I just ate up his his wonderful
series he sent to man and and I mean and
he's just brilliant anyway we could go
into that some other time but one of his
favorite quotes which I put in the
epilogue of the book is dream or
nightmare we have to live our experience
as it is and we have to live it awake we
live in a world which is penetrated
through and through by science and which
is both whole and real we cannot turn it
into a game simply by taking sides and I
think that's we that's really important
in our society now people who claim to
know everything and I I tend to think
that all these culture wars would be so
much better if people just said you know
I don't know I should listen but that's
also true among scientists you can't you
know it's not it's sure it's a game but
you can't but taking sides is fine if
you're willing to change sides uh in the
middle of the game yeah I mean I used to
say when I give a talk that the reason
that so many people love astronomy is
because there's no you know Republican
constellation or you know there's a
democratic asteroid over there but uh
increasingly science is becoming more
and more politicized you've pointed out
and you're not a culture Warrior but I
think you're a reluctant battler in this
in this uh Descent of scientific
Prestige and I always say we have to be
very careful in what you and I do I
think is important outside of the
science that we do is the communication
that we do because typically what
someone will say is uh you know I'm very
specialized you know I've got this giant
brain yeah you paid for it because your
taxes and so forth and every scientist
I'm supported by you know the most
private funding of almost any person not
me personally but the Simon's
Observatory the Simon's array by Jim
Simon's magnificence right so I'm
support but I got my education I teach
at a private school at a public school
rather I work for the governor of
California right so this the point is uh
and used to be the same in the regions
of Arizona State University so but
Lawrence
three private schools and then one
Public Schools exactly right so but even
if you're private I mean you were funded
by the National Science Foundation for
many years it's part of energy for most
minutes
they paid me to hang around and have fun
and what if you forgot
yeah and if you had a business I mean
you and I aren't businessmen but but we
had a business and we had an employee
and said you know Brian or Lawrence you
know you can't really understand what
I'm doing it's very special as you know
keep shoveling in the money I think what
we do is very important that we
communicate to the public about the
state of science because the moment that
the public loses confidence in the
scientific Enterprise I I think it's
game over I think it's Checkmate so
you're doing very importantly
unfortunately and I know that you're so
let's talk about it so let's let's I'm
going to reveal something I haven't
revealed and I want to get your reaction
to it so um so Jordan Peterson our
mutual friend yeah he came to visit me a
couple months ago we hit it off uh I've
been on his podcast you've been on his
podcast you've had him on your podcast
he's coming on my pocket he's starting a
new Endeavor called the Peterson Academy
which is uh for-profit but very low cost
accredited educational institution
they've asked me to be a professor at
this institution I've agreed
um this is are you gonna quit your
present Institution no so no I sorry
because I'm skeptical with all these
institutions people are professors I've
been a professor at some institutions
that I show up a week a year on two but
anyway right no so this is more akin to
you know teaching at at a uh you know
giving a seminar doing stuff like that
it'll be it'll be for credit and and
there will be you know there's a small
amount of money which I'm going to
donate as I have in the past to lowering
the cost for undergraduate scholarships
and graduate fellowships here for women
at UC San Diego so I've done that um
that's that's already pre-decented yeah
so I think the the question I'm asking
you that Academy has uh no political
ideology you're supposed to get a degree
in philosophy or green whatever not
physics I mean they're not degrees in
physics what do you make of this and and
in terms of the the you know the the
um the future of education is what I'm
most interested in your in your opinion
so because it's changed a lot since I I
became a professor and I imagine since
you became a professor what do you think
about the future of Education in the
context of some of the themes of this
book where you get into artificial
intelligence you start to talk about the
emergence of these natural language
models what do you think is the future
of our profession how can it remain the
same as it was in the year 1100 in
Bologna Italy when some guy was standing
up and scratching on a piece of Rock
with another piece of rock how can we
maintain this Monopoly this cartel this
you know for for a millennium is is the
end in sight
um you know I was funny I was just
listening to a book by barterman on
Revelations on the way back in my car
and listening to all of the end in sight
you know nonsense that that's been
involved not over the centuries look
first of all I don't know I'm sure I've
told you this before I don't make
predictions about the future unless it's
two trillion years in the future which
in which first of all I think I can say
some things with confidence and secondly
I can say with even more confidence that
no one's going to be able to around him
to check me to see if I'm wrong so the
near term is much harder and I I don't
know what the future is and in fact it
it's because I don't know what the
future is that I spend time
to writing about things that I'm
concerned about because if I knew how
things were going to turn out it
wouldn't be worth it but I try and have
some kind of impact one way or another
in my writing speaking and other things
that
education now it's higher education in
the US in particular is in a sad State
and I've written about it extensively as
you know
um free speech this notion of of uh of
of
the the secular religion of assuming
things are true and then and then not
allowing anyone to question it that's
the worst part
education should be based on constant
question that's why you know that's why
my book is whether it's it's questions
every chapter begins with questions
that's how we move forward and if you
can't question something and that's
happening too often and it used to just
happen in the humanities and to some
extent social sciences when I taught at
Yale
the science departments were on this
thing called Science Hill at Yale which
we thought was allegorical as well but
um but most students didn't make their
way up the hill but but we would laugh
we'd look at the deconstructionist
literature Department English department
down the hill and then we and what's
happening unfortunately is those things
are happening throughout higher
education and a sense of fear
I mean questioning stops when you're
afraid that question and that's that's
and it's that fear that scares me the
most and I've seen it happen when I
write something in particular Yeah well
yeah and Yale is just one of many but
Yale in particular and but but you know
when I've written things uh uh that I've
get I uh newspaper op-eds and say the
Wall Street Journal is somewhere else I
I've gotten letters from academics under
pseudonyms or from private accounts
saying they're they're writing me they
agree but they're afraid they're afraid
to do it from their institutional
account and that I mean 40 years ago
that would have just been impossible to
imagine at least in my experience and of
course it may have been limited there
were people actually my my friend Noam
Chomsky says that you know it's nothing
new to him cancer culture is you know
goes back 50 years a lot longer but so
there are problems I I am dubious of of
this of Jordan's Solutions I mean I
think it's
I I normally I talked about this in
terms of another proposed solution
there's a University of Austin which is
which has been proposed to trying
somehow involved Free Speech
these will always be peripheral and and
because you know the heart the heart of
of higher educational institutions
research institutions is the research
that goes on the teaching you get the
benefit
I mean liberal arts colleges are
fantastic let me I'm not saying they're
not important I think they're wonderful
it's one of the things that's wonderful
about the US is how many of them there
are I got involved in I actually for a
while a for-profit liberal arts college
in England for the precisely that reason
that they didn't have them but um but
what's great about being at a research
institution if you're there and it's not
for everyone is that you get access to
people who are who are who are pushing
those forefronts and their excitement
their curiosity somehow can be conveyed
to you and also if you're lucky and
undergraduates are in various places and
as well as grad students you can
participate in that Voyage of Discovery
and and and that's wonderful and um
so
I think those will always
I think at a higher you at a higher
education level those will always be the
driving forces of Education
it's true that a recent major research
institutions many faculty don't give a
hoot about teaching and you get often
get much better teachers at liberal arts
colleges but it's not always that way
and it's that it's that it's that
connection to that to that ongoing
search that's so important and I I just
don't see these
um I mean it's nice to have a place that
people can go and you hope it's not an
echo chamber for you know for your own
views and we'll see what happens with
the Peterson Academy I think the fact
that it's called the Peterson Academy is
likely to be self-selecting to some
extent and um you know I think it's
great it'll but it'll just be another
Cog it's not going to solve the problem
it's not going to say oh we exist and
now Yale is going to close its doors or
forget Yale I don't think that's the
goal but I mean like Harvard yeah but
you do look at these rapid phase shifts
that are occurring you know especially
in in the knowledge worker industry
thanks to these language models and as
you know and with your co-author Frank
wilcheck last year I recorded the first
ever uh audiobook by uh this guy thumb
uh here we go
okay so here's Galileo so he never had
it
yeah so he never had an audiobook so uh
I said this is a this is a Shonda this
is a claim this cannot stand and so
along with Carlo rivelli and Lucio
pacharillo Frank wilcheck Fabiola
gianates Jim Gates we recorded the first
ever audiobook of Galileo guess what
Lawrence I now have a million words
written by Galileo and you were just
saying before how you had us you were uh
you know motivating your undergraduate
institution to bump you up because of
this inclined plane you know nonsense
that all freshman physicists are
tortured by right but but why you know
whoever your teacher was I mean imagine
if he said well look inclined planes
were first studied by this guy Galileo
okay and guess what else he also wrote
like a poet and he was also a polymath
of of unparalleled Renown and in fact so
much so that if you study the true
controversy not to teach the controversy
about intelligence the controversy of
the time that got him thrown into jail
an assumptuous jail I have to say I mean
to give him his do I think I think
Bernie Madoff would have loved to be
yeah so so I mean Bruno didn't fare as
well but but anyway the point Bruno was
uh well anyway I'm I've heard
conflicting stories whether Bruno was
burned at the stake because of his
statement about stars or just because he
everyone hated him so much right and he
was basically espousing anti-church
Doctrine you know in addition to uh
Alien worlds but but anyway Lawrence the
point is like why sit there and learn
from as great a communicator as you
might be or or you know Brian green or
somebody like that why learn from them
when I can just sit there with an avatar
in three dimensions of Galileo and ask
him or Einstein or uh Richard Dawkins or
whoever you want to talk to Charles
Darwin and I can learn from them because
they've written at least a hundred
thousand words that's enough to make an
llm for them so why do you think why are
you so confident that at least the
undergraduate education won't change I
see it as very vulnerable oh I'm
convinced it will change I'm convinced I
mean things change and uh AI is going to
change the world as I talk about at the
end of the book what I'm not convinced
of is that it's going to make the world
just a dystopic future that's going to
destroy the world
um it could make it better as on the
example I used as what you know of is my
favorite one about Plato and Socrates
who in the starting the ninth and then
by the sixth Century
um BC in Greece after right after
writing had been introduced they hated
the idea of writing they said it would
destroy storytelling and I think
writing's been okay and so I suspect
things are going to change dramatically
in ways that we some of the ways we can
imagine but more excitingly in the ways
we can't and you know even as I read a
there was a lovely review of my book
this the other day by very thoughtfully
men who said well he crouched in you
know really worry about the fact that
super intelligent AI if if those things
ever going to exist is going to maybe
displace humans and what it what and I'm
not as worried about that even because I
think what will happen it's not going to
be a displacement it's going to be an
evolution of a change and humans to keep
up will have to incorporate aspects of
that technology and it'll change what it
means to be human but it already is
changed to be what it I mean what we do
every day is so different than than what
humans did 500 years ago that are ready
to be human is something very different
and so
um I don't I think you know it is
terrifying to not know what's going to
happen and and there are certain aspects
that do terrify me about AI mostly
capitalist ones mostly the fact that you
know um uh uh when when the Industrial
Revolution was uh Keynes argued the
Industrial Revolution would be great
because you know machines would come in
everyone having more leisure time that
the fruits to be more productive the
fruits of the productivity be shared
military
coffee shops and and I've heard you know
I've my friend Jeffy sax who's an
economist say that would be a great
future for sure it's okay if it's okay
if AI displaces most jobs if the rest of
us can spend time in coffee houses
listening to music and having great
conversations but I suspect and that
given the way things already going that
instead it's going to concentrate wealth
in a fewer and fewer hands the people
who have the first AI that can do X Y or
Z and and so it it made it may produce
more economic chaos but one you know
when I wrote the climate change books I
I said that one of my favorite phrases
from that book was that the future is
charging at us like a freight train but
it's doing so on tracks that we've built
so we could you know it we do have the
virtue of having prepared Minds if we if
we are willing to discuss these problems
and think about them and that therefore
the future is a no I you know one of
one of my uh
favorite lines because I was first when
I first discovered my name is Lawrence I
didn't know my name was Lawrence when I
was younger it was a different name and
um but we're on the same time as the
movie Lawrence Arabia came out before
you were born
um I I fell in love with that movie my
favorite line in the movie is where he
goes out into the desert and he saves
this young boys falling off his camel
and they say that you know it's it he's
it's it's dead it's it's written and he
comes back and almost dead the next day
he comes in nothing is written I
remember that as a 12 year old or 10
year old and I thought that is that's
what's great nothing is written nothing
is written and and that that's what's so
wonderful about that's why for me this
is a such a a labor of love yeah the
future isn't written the future of
science isn't written and it can go in
so many different directions and and and
and we can celebrate that excitement
because that future is also Humanity's
future it's also our cultural future uh
uh the idea is the things you're going
to shape what it means to be human and
what it means to the joy of Being Human
and and the fact that the next great
piece of music isn't written yet and the
negrex great piece of literature isn't
written yet uh all of those things make
waking up every day more fun yeah I
agree and and speaking back of
capitalism I mean we can't ignore the
well I don't know if he's still the
richest man in the known universe uh but
Elon Musk and I want to Pivot back to
the very beginning I'm hard to lose that
well well yeah he's
I'm contributing I know you are too the
eight bucks no no no no no I'm not in
fact okay you got it for free but I will
really this to make you jealous okay
please do yeah yeah please leave the man
I lost my blue tick and Eli I happen to
be in communication with Elon and Elon
said oh I'll pay for yours if you want
and I swear I I didn't accept that
initially and I don't know if it was a
mistake but it was nice one to say it
but anyway oh that is okay so um let's
talk about Elon so this morning I had a
response to Elon because he sent out
some tweet that was basically uh that
the existence of the plank length
somehow limits and diminishes or puts a
practical limit whatever that means on
the number of digits of pi so let's go
back to the very beginning of the of the
edge of knowledge where we talk about
space is it true is there anything
um actually important relevant about the
Planck length first of all because I
made the point that if that were true
then there's nothing relevant about two
times the Planck length because we also
don't have any evidence about anything
below two times the plane
uh what level does it matter when we
actually have calculation that we had
done 20 years ago and which hasn't been
publicized very much what is I think he
understood it which is that Quantum
um quantum mechanics
um and and and
uh puts limits on Computing not a
quantum computer can be reversible
that's fine it can it can be reverse fun
and therefore it doesn't dissipate any
energy but every time you want to do new
computation generally you have to erase
a register and that dissipates at least
State one H bar CEO you know because of
quantum mechanics a fine amount of
energy and actually my actually a former
another Case Western Professor Glenn
starkman who was um very well and I
wrote a Pete wrote a paper which did a
calculation saying assume you know
asking the question given especially
given an eternally expanding Universe
how how much is there a limit to the
total number of computations you can do
and we argued there was from that and it
comes from quantum mechanics ultimately
from the Flack The Plank scale because
you couldn't you couldn't cool things
down more or less before below the
Planck temperature and that would give a
I mean this is all hypothetical gave a
limit I think we came up with a 10 to
the 120 bits of uh to be but you know I
don't think it in fact like many of my
favorite papers that one um never got
accepted but um uh and so because of the
archive I didn't need to it's out there
but um but I think so I think if there's
any sense I didn't know I saw that and I
thought well it wasn't well not
necessarily an irresponsible thing to
say but I don't know it's fine that's
fine to say it it doesn't he said more
irresponsible things Lawrence he's
actually said something more
irresponsible I'm sure no I know I know
but but but but
um and so do I I'm sure but uh so you
know as you would say let me not the
first one to cast the first stone you
know someone said that in the Bible but
uh a Jewish guy said that yeah a Jewish
guy yeah but anyway uh the more
important thing is that I think it
doesn't put a limit on my
in any way I understand the number of
limits the digits of pi but on your
ability to calculate the digits of pi
yes sure yeah but but I guess that's a
deeper question than what elon's asking
I mean you could say the same about like
the back is the plank length does that
produce a limit on the number of prime
numbers there are it's totally
irrelevant it's comparing literally
apples but I do want to ask you is there
operationally it's operation yeah and
then the plan and you but you hit on
another important Point yeah that you
don't realize you hit on but um okay
unintentionally Brilliance I'll take it
and that is that this notion that
understanding that understanding the
physics
uh Associated quantum gravity would give
you a Theory of Everything Is is
ludicrous for many reasons it's actually
a theory of very not a very little
almost nothing it's vitally important
for those of us who are interested in
How the Universe began or what happens
at the center of black hole but to calc
to figure to understand almost
everything else that happens in the
universe quantum gravity is just
irrelevant it's not it's a theory of
almost nothing it's profoundly
intellectually important but to
understand how water boils you don't
have to have a theory of quantum gravity
and produce and no matter what Roger
Penrose may think it's this fact that in
order to understand how the brain works
you don't need a theory of quantum
gravity and so it is important for a
limited set of questions which are not
and I don't want to minimize them
because I spend a lot of my life
worrying about them you know how did the
universe begin and I think most people
are fascinated by it so intellectually
they're incredibly important but
operationally as far as the progress of
science is concerned it's not it's just
a theory of very little yeah and
thinking about Quantum Computing which
you get to towards the end of the book
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
Consciousness I just want to remind
everybody we're talking to the renowned
physicist Communicator educator film
star many other accolades and honors and
that's Lawrence Krauss who is the
proprietor of a rival podcast called the
origins project podcast which competes
against the into the impossible podcast
raises All Ships I don't think that's
right we've shared guests we've
communicated back and forth about uh
about guests we've had on many many
eminent people income and we have a
different you know we should go on the
road in fact we're planning to go on the
road here at least this is an event with
you stay home San Diego that's right so
we're working on that so I'll have some
news for you after the podcast ends
hopefully some good news but Lawrence
the uh what you do in the theoretical
front on the uh kind of grand Vistas I
try to kind of concretize and what I'm
doing is is really talk about what are
these things good for that you brilliant
theorists come up with and try to shine
an experimentalist light on it and one
of those things you mentioned is Feynman
and Quantum Computing so if I'm in you
know basically said that these quantum
computers could be phenomenal at
describing the properties of quantum
computers he actually said it would be
they'd be incredibly unparalleled at
solving LeBron James now I don't know
about you but I you know I get along
just fine with this thing which only has
a paltry you know 15 billion transistors
in it but none of them are quantum what
good are quantum computers I mean in
reality there's hype around them is so
maximalized but in reality
yeah so tell me what what what's their
promise
well okay and and I and
and to mimic you I'll at least point out
uh that that I um in in the podcast the
origins podcast I had a good
conversation with an old colleague of
mine and a friend for many years John
presco who leads a Quantum Computing
effort at Caltech to ask exactly that
question I think look there are two
things that quantum computers will be
good at if they you know if if they can
achieve even a small fraction of the
hype that they get
um one is of great interest to
physicists and to Feynman they will be
wonderful at solving quantum mechanical
quantum mechanics problems and giving us
insight into the behavioral quantum
mechanics because they utilize quantum
mechanics in the in the calculation so
they can intrinsically do quantum
mechanical calculations that we can't do
because we we you know process things
classically so from a scientific
perspective to even make progress in
scientific problems you don't need many
qubits you know so I'm suspicious you
know of of how easily it'll be to scale
up a quantum computer to do a lot of the
stuff that people claim but you don't
need more than you know 40 or 50 cubits
even even if that to begin to do some
kind of problems of solving the
molecular Dynamics and that sort of
thing so and that's by the way what
interested fireman fireman said the
great thing about a quantum computer is
would help him understand quantum
mechanics and you know and a lot of
people think he had a good understanding
of quantum mechanics but but ultimately
we can't because we're classical beings
and part of the one of the things I
really enjoyed being able to do in the
edge of knowledge was to talk about
quantum mechanics from a different
perspective because there's so much
nonsense so much pseudom mysticism
applied by even by physicists to write
book write books about you know the many
worlds interpretation and called
something else but but um you know and
it's really in my mind misplaced because
it's you they took the interpretation of
quantum mechanics which is really the
wrong thing to do because the world is
quantum mechanical on its basis and
Cloud the classical world is an illusion
so to try and interpret Quantic X in
terms of the illusion is the wrong way
around you should interpret the
classical World in terms of the
fundamental Quantum games and it was
Sydney Coleman who first who was at
Harvard and as I point out certainly was
a meant it was a friend and and now not
really a mentor but a the smartest
person in Harvard when I was there
um and and he was he gave a great
lecture called quantum mechanics in your
face and I was able to reproduce a
little bit of it by talking about the
fact that that you know that all this
way of talking with spooky action at a
distance and trying to make it seem
sensible or at least
caulking In classical terms is just that
it's cloaking and and finally realized
that and said well a quantum computer
won't have to do that it'll it'll just
do quantum mechanical calculations now
the next thing a quantum computer could
be good at because precisely because
Quantum systems are doing many things at
the same time
and they are like it or not that if you
have quantum mechanical bits qubits that
are doing many things at the same time
especially when you're not measuring
them
then you can imagine a computer that can
do many parallel computations at the
same time that's right and therefore so
many that um that a classical computer
could never could never do that in a
reasonable amount of time and if you had
enough qubits you could imagine
therefore doing incredibly complicated
calculations that you wouldn't be able
to do in the lifetime of the universe
classically Quantum mechanically because
you're doing many many computations at
the same time they're the ultimate
parallelizable systems if you want
because you know electron when you don't
measure it is spinning in all directions
at the same time and so quantum
mechanics would tell us if you I mean
again that's a classical picture what's
really happening but right but um
and so they hold out some promise but
the question is the reason
the reason quantum mechanics is so
counter-intuitive is because it doesn't
manifest itself easily in the in the in
the world that you and I live in I mean
that's true it is true that my that the
phone that you talk about is depends
vitally on quantum mechanics
semiconductors and transistors depend
rightly on quantum mechanics and and so
we rely on it for using it but the world
you know is I I I like you know I can
run at my wall for now to the end of
time and I'll never end up on the other
side but electron going through a
barrier can do that and so that's right
as I learned from John McGreevy yeah
it's all those things that make the
world classical that make it difficult
to maintain these special conditions
that that the quantum World requires for
the weirdness of quantum mechanics to be
manifest there's certain places like in
superconductivity where it is Manifest
and there's certain cases where if
you're very carefully prepared a system
you can do that quantum teleportation of
a few States but but the the idea of
having law large-scale computers that
I'll be having
Quantum mechanically in that sense with
Quantum coherence and correlations
preserved is difficult and maybe not
impossible there's been great progress
but that's the difficulty in a matching
quantum computers being scaled up and
many many people are working very very
hard and already you know achieving
things that surprised me so I'm not
going to say I think 10 years ago I
would I said I don't think I you know I
don't think it's going to happen my
lifetime that these things will be
workable on a logged enough scale to
provide anything substantively new and
now I think I'm more hesitant and it's
one of those many cases where I love to
be proved wrong because yeah that's the
most exciting right the most exciting
you know words in science according to
Isaac it's only it's only slightly lower
excitement than proving you wrong
well it's it's much harder to do to
prove me wrong as you know no you you uh
I I was I was delighted to see my
experiment gets a call out and a shout
out in this book bicep two uh but I I
don't appear but that's fine but anyway
a person that does appear uh we talk
about dollars a month that was the
problem anyway
I didn't get my uh my my uh blue and
gray Spartan blue check mark anyway uh
so my colleague uh after I went to Case
Western and barely evaded your uh harsh
grading rubric I went to Brown
University where my Advanced quantum
mechanics Professor was none other than
Leon Cooper and Leon uh was a was a
character still is he still wrote a
great undergraduate text by the way
which I used when I taught physics for
poets I thought it was a great text
anyway but he did not with his colleague
bardeen John bardeen uh his his
colleague John bardeen who is the
co-inventor of the transistor the only
person as you know to win two physics
Nobel prizes uh but bardeen didn't look
at the laws of quantum mechanics and say
let me put this Crystal of germanium and
then this coat hanger and then some some
chewing gum and they just they
engineered it it was more of an
engineering solution so it seems to me
quantum Computing is sort of the
opposite like we're starting from
lagrangian and we're trying to derive
something useful they stumbled upon you
know this this varister and these uh
through trial and error at some level
and they came up you know on the heels
of vacuum tubes and and Di nodes and
stuff like that and then came up with a
working device so it seems to me
fundamentally qualitatively different I
don't expect a response but I was just
going to say I don't know to what extent
do you like let me ask a question let me
let me ask the question alarm so the
question is the following I hear I've
heard it said by past guest and and
friend of mine personally in front of
the show Eric Weinstein that you know if
we do come up with a unified theory or a
theory of everything then we can look
into it and it will help us solve you
know Mysteries of the universe perhaps
even teleportation perhaps even you know
time transportation whatever I don't ask
you to react to that but the notion that
physicists somehow from the equations
alone derive technology I think that
that's uh that's that's inaccurate so
how do you react to that based on the
example that we didn't look at uh
lagrangi and the schrodden equation say
oh well let's make a transistor instead
the transistor emerge from engineering
Solutions so can we hope to get time
travel and other things if we did get a
unified theory of space and time well
look I think the point is that that
technological Discovery is also uh
serendipitous at its in many at its most
interesting level
it's true that they weren't using
lagrangians to build a transistor but at
the same time if they've been told we
need you to make a faster computer
well at Bell Labs will spend all our
money trying to make a faster computer
they would have had wheels and they
would have had you know pulleys and
wheels smaller vacuum tubes yeah and so
what often drives the greatest
technological discoveries is people just
being curiosity driven they may not be
driven by equations they may not even
know what they're doing just like
theorists don't often I mean some of my
most important papers are things that I
really I don't think I understood till
well after they were they were written
and I think the same and I'm not putting
myself in planned on the same thing but
having written a lot about Einstein it's
clear that I think that's true of
Einstein as well
um in in some of his more important
papers he didn't really appreciate until
after the fact a general relativity is
just the importance of but but
gravitational waves and black holes and
things like that yeah that's true so
let's let's sorry go on but anyway so I
think that's it I think so it's it's
just people playing
and sometimes the series playing but
you're right it's rarely the theorists
are playing and suddenly technology
emerges it's it's
but but here's the thing there will be
Engineers
there might be I don't want to say will
be because it sounds like a prediction
um the the special prediction that could
be falsified
um but uh there may be
you know I I when I was a case one of
the things I was proud of and I did a
lot of things as chair Cason I'm proud
of including our most effectively there
now but we've developed an engineering
physics program which was the best of
both worlds for many students their
parents wanted to be Engineers as you
know probably your parents one of the
reasons people went to case is they were
they were you know often working class
kids and their parents said no we don't
want to do physics we won't get a job we
need to be an engineer and and and so
but you know but here they could get a
training in physics which is not just
applying you know plug and chug like too
often engineering was but you know that
learning how to solve problems and most
as I as I used to say which is true when
I was trying to get students to take the
program or at least talk to parents
about it is most physicists are actually
employed as engineers in the in the
world today it's because they know how
to solve problems they may not know the
details of that an engineer knows an
electrical engineer knows about a
circuit but they can solve problems and
learn those things
but but but what I'm gonna get at is
just that simply 20 years from now the
engineers of the future may be playing
with things that come from lagrangea for
them it may be second nature to play
with the tools that are generated by
Quantum Computing and do their thing
just like for bardeen you know working
with coat hangers and and you know and
and soldering guns may have been there
too so so I don't know if it won't be
down the road something very similar and
I I that's all I wanted to get yeah no I
agree and I always say if you want to
prove you know thevenin's theorem in in
11 Dimensions ask an electrical engineer
but if you want an actual circuit that
works or your toaster's broken and
you've pointed out many times I love uh
to to steal your quote uh you know the
problem with science is sometimes it
produces technology and uh and and that
is it leads to these expectations that
you know this is the job and as I
discussed with Nobel Orion and past
professor at UC San Diego Duncan holiday
he said no you should come up with
useless ideas the useless
yeah yeah but but you know you in that
same quote which is what is a it's a
quote I'm happy about I'm glad you
quoted it and more I'm even happier you
you referenced me appropriately but um
uh is is the statement that that um uh
um
not only
um I was going to say now um that oh
yeah that that not only uh is it as
unfortunate byproduct of Sciences
technology because people expect then
don't think the science is important
unless it produces technology but but
the same token it is remarkable to me
that the other areas of human activity
that I view as as equivalent to science
in this in the sense of celebrating the
mandated people arts and literature and
music people never say that about about
a about a Mozart symphony or or you know
or a newborn baby right they never say
oh what good is this newborn baby is I
don't want to even use that example
because yeah it's overused but I like to
think because the newborn baby may
actually be useful but but but a a um
but a Mozart Symphony and a Picasso
painting will never produce a better car
it'll just inspire people to think of
themselves a slightly different way and
um and you know or yeah so I want to
Pivot to uh let's talk about Eric
Clapton anyway to another yeah yeah
anyway sorry yeah so I want to Pivot to
uh the chap chapters on life so we'll
talk later about uh some of my favorite
quotes that you pull out from
Schrodinger and other people but but uh
the quote uh that I want to Pivot to uh
first is is actually with respect to
life so I had on andrewian who is Carl
Sagan's Widow you you have a lot of uh
uh a conversation about Carl in this
book and and you have a scene or you
describe this what happened in 1997 I
think it was and the White House lawn
which is depicted in the movie contact
many people think that this is nonsense
CGI no no no Bill Clinton is really
there and he's really saying this
discovery if confirmed we'll be the
greatest discovery of all time he was
talking about the discovery of allegedly
microbial life found in the Allen Hills
meteorites which was a project uh
originally there's the ansment program
that you probably helped participate in
at Case Western it's still alive and
kicking and they found this meteorite
sitting on a piece of of ice chunk in
Antarctica where I've been a couple
times you've been there a couple times
too The Edge I've been to the South Pole
yeah
hoping that they would take me but they
never did yeah well the meteorite's not
found in the South Pole it's found in
the Allen I know I know I know so they
zoomed in on it and they so I want to
run this argument by you you talk about
in the book in the chapter on life you
say what is life is life elsewhere in
the universe and hearkening back to that
press conference which by the way was
the basis of not only a refereed and
published paper in science uh but also
the subject of the NASA astrobiology
project led by Dan golden back in the 19
late 1990s it led to a lot of funding
for NASA astrobiology okay yeah so that
was never retracted
yeah yeah that was never retracted that
paper it was never officially the Maya
culpa I think the point is yeah that
well you know so the point is that it
yeah I I think they made a it's
interesting that wasn't retracted the
question is what the claims they made if
they if they made this the claim that
this might be then no need to retract if
they made the claim that it was then it
would be need to be retracted just like
get you're too young again but you won't
remember you should remember you
probably do
um my good friend Bloss Cabrera who
discovered Valentine's Day event I have
a video right inactive Valentine's Day
and and that paper I'm sure hasn't been
tracked either because no one you know
it was a a weird anomalous observation
and it at the time it looked like it was
exactly what was expected if a monopole
existed and it wasn't but you know so
sometimes you know there are weird
enormous results so anyway I don't you
know there's reasons to retract papers
but if they if a paper provokes things
and doesn't make claims that are you
know that strong claims that are not
wrong and I don't mind if it's you know
if it's also I didn't know I didn't know
that they never that they never tracked
it but again I didn't read the I never
read the original paper so yeah the the
the paper is generally guarded as you
know drawing incorrect inference but at
the time it was the best obviously it
led to this huge attention and so forth
it's not as bad as a paper that
suggested uh phosphorus replaced uh that
arsenic Vice
and that I don't think I don't know if
that paper has ever been retracted and
that's just it has not been retracted so
this is this is replete and and actually
I should say that my own experience
bicep 2 paper was never we never
retracted it we did a follow-up
observation with Planck we showed the
conclusions were consistent with dust
but we didn't say may culpa we shouldn't
have claimed the first direct evidence
for inflation my hands are no cleaner as
your friend she's a big defender of it
as you know because they asked me to
write the companion piece when it came
up but they know yes I know it it uh it
was unlucky but that's about my claim is
that we should we should have a
publicity budget for papers and academic
media hype complex that I call it we
should also have a budget for
retractions but let's not go there right
now I want to talk about that Martian
media let's get back to publicizing and
the university spend most of their time
doing it to try and get money and it's
unfortunately I think actually today
they should have an equal they should
have a 10 Reserve in a lock box for for
rich attractions learns because it gives
the wrong impression that scientists I
still get people telling me Lawrence oh
you were part you discovered
gravitational waves from inflation like
today I get asked about that and by
scientists this isn't just by my
mother's dry cleaner I'm talking about
something that happens among scientific
Elites anyway Lawrence get back to this
meteorite which by the way that's all
part of saying we don't know and we
we're wrong and that's all and and
you're right and part of the reason that
the universities need to do that is
they're so low to say they're wrong
about anything nowadays anyways that's
right so let's talk about meteorites so
first of all I want to say that if
you're listening to this on your on
Lawrence's podcast or uh you're finding
it somewhere if you have a edu email
address and you go to Brian keating.com
list I will send you a chunk of an
actual meteorite and the reason I do
that for edu is because I'm trying to uh
to have a connection between all these
young people that are in college and
hopefully influence them to the good to
understand appreciate the positives as
you're pointing out and celebrating
rightfully about science but also as
Lawrence is saying the cautionary tales
when we should have that piece of paper
in our pocket that says we're dust this
is a piece of space dust anyway Lawrence
if I told you that my friend down the
hall uh Shelly Wright or one of her
colleagues here at UCSD who's on the
NASA Panel LED by David spurgle to look
into the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial phenomena anyway if I told her
her colleagues have found a planet okay
there's a planet out there and it's next
to a planet and that planet has is is is
rotten with life that planet is just
completely overrun with life and uh and
it's actually this other planet that's
neighboring that planet is in the
habitable zone of its host star it's a
type G you know sub Giant and it has a
liquid it has liquid water vapor on its
surface it's had flowing rivers on it
it's had on many different climatary
changes it has carbon dioxide in it
which is a biomarker potentially so if I
told you all that once and I said that
it's been exchanging material as the
Earth has you know for Millions
um uh with that life-giving planet
potentially what would you say the odds
are that that neighboring Planet also
has life would you could you say
anything I'm not asking you don't tell
me the exact Earth but would you would
that increase the Bayesian confidence
that that neighboring planet has life on
it
yeah yeah I know I mean okay you're
gonna get Mars and Earth uh but here we
go yeah so now I say it's Mars and Earth
so the fact that we don't see life
can I say anything as I'm just a dumb
experimentalist okay don't don't be too
harsh at me but can you say anything
what no go ahead I'm gonna bite my
tongue okay can you say anything about
the facundity arguments that life is
abundant as as Carl Sagan and andrean
say if there's no life in the universe
it's an awful waste of space well I've
been to Antarctica twice there's an
awful wasted space down there too and
one seventh of the Earth's habitable
continent so Lawrence the
non-observation of Life on Mars given
it's next to a son fertile neighbor
that's pumping out kids you know on a
daily basis can we not say anything
about the difficult
living life in the cosmos at Large
no I don't think so I mean so first of
all it's extremely difficult to
extrapolate from a an example one a
single case right we all know that okay
even mathematicians generally need two
to do an infinite regression but um so
to to uh what we what we can say it
seems to me and I try and say in the
book is that
is that because
we know that Mars and Earth exchange
material
and because Mars appears too early on
have been more amenable with the
conditions to the life like we know it
that it's not impossible that when you
want to look see what a martian looks
like look in the mirror that that light
first arose on Mars but we also know
that Mars as a planet had certain
features that ours doesn't and evolved
in a way that made it inhospitable and
um and and so what will be very
important is actual data I know as an
experimentalist I assume you actually
like data
like like data come on exactly well I'm
a theorist who happens what happens to
like data and maybe yes you do
increasingly rare but but I'm an
old-fashioned guy and and what I would
like is data on on on either extinct or
extant Life on Mars which would give me
some ability to extrapolate but more
interestingly to me and and as I
describe in the book is is would be data
from A system that hasn't been able to
exchange material with the Earth like
the oceans in Europa are Enceladus and
if they were discovered to be organism
is microbial organisms in those regions
that would that would be much more
powerful evidence that there could be a
second generation Genesis of life even
in our solar system which would have
profound implications for the abundance
of life in the universe but right now we
know almost nothing because you know of
one example of life which is part of the
problem I wrote a piece as you know
recently on astrobiology and these
problems and much of the hype in
astrobiology which is
another which is a field which has a lot
of hype as well as unfortunately filled
with mixed scientific um
credentials I guess or I don't know how
to put it
um
is that we we know so little that that
most claims are are are highly suspect
but but that's okay because it means
there's so much to learn now unlike say
quantum gravity where we may never learn
what what what the universe is like at
those scales what's great about about us
about astronomy and what will eventually
be I think interesting about
astronomology is we have all these tools
we have tools that are going to allow us
to explore not just our solar system but
look at extrasolar planets and explore
their atmospheres
um looking for Bio markers so
so the next 20 to 30 years could be
replete with data which will change our
picture and that makes it exciting but
we but we shouldn't pretend we do we
know now when we really don't know
almost anything about life about the
life in the universe
and one a wonderful aspect of light of
the edge of knowledge your latest um
epic Tome is you talk about the Drake
equation and you kind of slip it in um
but I I was appreciative of it you
basically say it's it's um how do you
describe it you describe it as sort of
like a Talisman or you don't even call
it an equation it's a mnemonic that's
right yeah so I know Frank I Used to
Know Frank Drake but it's not an
equation 62 years ago he came up with
his eponymous equation and uh and it's
used replete you know the people you can
buy T-shirts with it uh uh but I always
point out to my students it's actually
just kind of like Hubble in a sense like
Hubble if you look at his 1929 paper
he's got this plot and it's a plot of
distance versus philosophy the units of
velocity are given as kilometers uh you
know it's kind of uh unbelievable and
this is in the proceedings of the
National Academy of Science
well yes that's right but uh yes uh so
so and that but the idea was was right
he was wrong the data were inconclusive
they had no error bars on them Lawrence
come on would you have given me if I
submitted to you a lab report with my
Factor 10 too it was run by a factor of
at least seven or multiple popular
anyway but but the idea is right so how
do you handle that as a as a theory that
that there may be people who have the
right ideas
um or maybe the wrong data or something
like that but still lead to I mean where
else does that happen where else do you
make like I accidentally made a car or I
accidentally made a transistor that
doesn't happen there's serendipitous
discoveries penicillin or whatever but
it's very different from an engineering
solution so how does that occur I mean
how does the human mind we're going to
Pivot to Consciousness next and then
we're going to get to some audience
questions and then we're going to finish
up with my existential uh final question
okay I'm glad yeah yeah
if you have time we'll keep going okay
good no no no I pushed it off I I told
my students you know office hours are
canceled you're on your own for the for
the midterm and Lawrence priorities
that's good
so um
is that unique
mind uh the reason I'm getting to this
when we talk about Consciousness you
have a quote you have two quotes that I
love and I'm gonna retweet them I'm not
going to give you credit because you
didn't say it but but these two people
said it you said no problem can be
solved from the same level of
Consciousness that created it and going
back to artificial intelligence you
remember what Einstein said was his
happiest thought Lawrence
well I remember the one that I'm
thinking about was when it was well I
knew the one that gave him palpitations
was when he was when he discovered that
the Prairie alien and Mercury agreed
with his calculations which is which for
me is really important because people
think you know it was this act of magic
of work sitting in his room alone
imagining what the world looked like he
was driven by data I guess but anyway
yes so his happy are going to give you a
minonic I can never pronounce it right
uh that and and Co and coax or Cokes I
always get wrong because I'm I'm
experimentalist okay here's a here's a
hint here's a hint
you see that yeah you see what just
happened to him what happened to
Einstein there what happened to him here
he freaking what he went into free fall
so his happiness I thought when he
realized that FIFA was the same as
weightlessness to me so can I ask you
Lawrence in the future will this device
or something like it this this device
that we're communicating on can it a
have a happiest thought and B Can it
have a perception at the edge of
knowledge of what it's like to Free Fall
if it's bound up in a Quantum lagrangea
system well no in fact actually if if
you read my book carefully you'll
discover that um uh I I talk about that
and I mean again these are not due to me
but um yeah I think it's incredibly
important and I think I I find it
plausible and I think that's all we as I
say that's all we can do with custom
Consciousness right now but highly
plausible that the no that an integral
part of the development of The
evolutionary development of
Consciousness is is uh feelings is being
able is the time is is it necessity for
homeostasis which means you have to have
sensors that probe to see how the body
is behaving and that goes all the way
back to to bacteria and ultimately being
able to do that in a more refined sense
required a central processing system and
and it has been said uh by uh by at
least one well-known neuroscientist and
maybe more that if a system doesn't have
basically a body
that can sense the outside environment
and and and feedback on on itself that
it can never really be conscious that
that's a central part of the development
of Consciousness and it sounds and sorry
to interrupt you Lauren sorry to
interrupt you but your good friend Noam
Chomsky seems to have you know this
notion of a generative grammar which in
part when I talk to him on my podcast he
said it was very unlikely that you could
develop a language system without a body
without an embodiment so is that is that
do you share those same skepticisms I
mean I share a lot but no not everything
but I certainly I I sh he was like many
things he's taught me a lot or at least
caused me to think about the world
differently than I did before and one of
his statements that really and I I
forget if I talked about it in in that
conscious chapter is it language which
is for many people synonymous with
consciousness
annulments argue that language isn't for
communication at all it's for it's it's
it's for internal it's it's it's it's an
eternal process and it's a central part
of our cognitive being but but
communication was really secondary that
language isn't developed for
communicating and that's amazing when I
first when I first heard him say that it
really took me back
um and but it sound again it seems
plausible
I don't know and and this is the hard
part this is why I said in the book that
studying Consciousness is like studying
quantum gravity or studying the universe
because we're stuck in our universe so
it's pretty hard to get outside but just
like we're stuck in our heads and it's
pretty hard to get out of it at the same
time we can't probe quantum gravity
because we don't have those damn
experimental tools that and and you can
never at least at this point know what
I'm thinking other than me telling you
which is a lie you know which is a lie
that my myself has created as not sort
of this picture of of the universe that
I that I have uh right so it's not me
lying directly but so I think that but
one thing that I have and maybe you have
the same is that I cannot imagine
thinking of something without language I
mean I think about things pictorially
but it's so integrated my own mind to
that internal dialogue that I'm having
with myself that's why I don't think I
can ever get around language now it's
chicken and egg is is that just because
I learned language that I use it or is
it because it's an A and what how do you
know it's hard to know but as I said
because I'm such an admirer of
experimentalists quoting another
statement of our mutual uh hero I
suppose or one of certainly mine Richard
Feynman
is is he said you can build nothing
knows nothing or you know well actually
what he really said was if you can't
build it you can't understand it he once
told me if you can you can't build
anything knows nothing but I've never
seen it written down but he did tell me
that his famous statement on the
chalkboard of his office when he died
which was later occupied you don't
understand it that's the statement that
the world knows he said that I know the
statement he told me but anyway
um yes but if you can't build it you
don't understand it so I'm reasonably
just as reasonably convinced that the
only way we'll understand Consciousness
is if we can build it and have that AI
that everyone is so afraid of
um but as you just pointed out we may
not be able to do it in the directions
people are taking because it's as Noah
was pointed out among others chat gbt
and everything else as much as it
impresses people it's not it's not
thinking it's not understanding the
world he's just he's just classifying
information and data right it's auto
complete it's an article and that's
great and it's wonderful you can do that
but but it may need a body and it may
need many more things it's a wonderful
that's why we may need systems that are
much more like the systems that another
person I'm happy to say wrote something
nice about my book which is
unfortunately on the printed version of
the US one but Ian McEwen who's a friend
of mine and a wonderful author wrote a
uh
um wrote a great book and it was called
something like me what was it called
um there was about an it was about a
robot an AI a human like me or something
yeah yeah and I'm tempted to Google it
while I'm talking to you but go on yeah
it's okay so what yeah so I agree
actually again quoting my late father
you know who's used to say well
machine's like ah okay good very good so
uh my late father used to say yes we can
get a computer to act like us when we
make it feel pain because I think a lot
of uh is pain aversion we've shown from
psychological experiments to whatever
extent they passed the replication uh
crisis uh hypothesis that passed guest
uh Guido imbenz and I have spoken about
uh in in earlier this year but the point
being that we feel pain like when I'm in
a simulator like learning how to fly a
plane I've often thought that it'll be
great if there was a little electrode
that would like shock me because it's
really fun to like fly into a bridge on
the simulator but I wouldn't try that
with my kids screaming in the back right
so but if there's some disincentive they
blow their you blow a train transistor
inside the computer or you do something
in it to have it have not only the
operation of you know of its user which
says no that was a stupid prompt or that
was a stupid response to a brilliant
prompt by me chat jbt if instead you you
actually penalize it you know and punish
it perhaps that's a way forward to the
truth but let me get you to react to the
great Irwin Schrodinger who said the
following Consciousness is a singular of
which the plural is unknown you talk
about in this book some discussion by
David Chalmers whose past guest on this
podcast uh where I talked to David and I
said to him you know he's from Australia
and I said David look if I don't ask you
to define the hard problem of
Consciousness it's like I'm interviewing
AC DC and I don't ask them to Play Back
in Black I said we gotta do it okay
buddy so he did it and but I came away
feeling like the same essay that was
written the year I was born I think 1971
by Thomas Nagel what is it like to be a
bat conclusion I don't have any freaking
clue so yeah isn't this hopeless isn't
isn't uh Schrodinger's interpretation to
be hopeless and furthermore what if life
as you say it takes n of two for a
mathematician what if life is only on
this planet can we ever discuss what is
life and what is consciousness two
seminal questions of this book The Edge
of knowledge well look we don't again
the answer is we don't know but we can
try and that's wonderful and but but we
can ask the question we can try and
understand exactly what it is we don't
know and try and that'll help guide us
to try and get the answers and that's
what I that's why I frame those
questions and talk about in each chapter
I think the the life question is so much
easier the conscience is one I'm I'm not
optimistic
about that because I think it's so it's
such a hard it is such a hard problem
but not in the sense of traumas
necessarily but but there is a hard
you know it will actually no one said to
me I I don't know if it was in a podcast
but
um that you know we may just give up
trying to have this you know like
Maxwell had this picture of Maxwell's
equations and it was with
police
and wheels and all this stuff because he
needed this mechanistic picture we
dispense with that now we just have the
equations and it could be in the end we
dispense with this notion while we have
to have a picture of how conscious
emergence maybe we'll have at some level
of mathematical description or something
like it and we'll dispense with this
quaint notion that you have to
understand it by being able to compare
it to things you already know and it was
it was it was once again Feynman
um and it was it was Coleman remind me
of this in this great interview you know
that he did
um where someone asked him to explain
the force between you know magnets like
compared to the force between you know
you're sitting around the chair and he
said you've got it exactly wrong because
you the force sitting on the chair is
not fundamental it's it comes it it
arises because of the same kind of
forces between magnets so asking me to
explain the force G magnets in terms of
you sitting on this chair is exactly
asked backwards and and uh and so you
know that may be the case you know yeah
exactly so Lawrence we have a bunch of
uh questions from the audience and then
I'm going to Pivot to a few questions of
my own uh first of all I've been told as
a podcaster one should at times ask the
author and the guest if there's anything
that I have not covered and you would
like me to cover in particular Lawrence
well since I I don't go on your program
or generally any pro well sometimes I do
but generally I don't go on any program
with an agenda
um
and to try and be and reasonably
entertaining and informative so um no
there are many questions like like uh
there are many no there's nothing you've
you you know I think we you know in a
limited amount of time it would be nice
to spend more time on on the things that
we you know time and space and matter
the physical we'll do that we'll do that
this fall in San Diego yeah I'm hoping
we'll do that in San Diego and and I
should point out you have many other 18
ideas in its own little time that we
should I know yeah that's delightful
we're outside trying to come in but
anyway you you banished them out of my
room they hate you that's right well you
know it's it's not worse than what I did
to gnome I actually like almost yelled
at gnome when he was on three years ago
I could not hear my eardrums had
exploded after his dog went nuts in the
room that he was anyway he'll hopefully
have forbearance and maybe he'll come
back on the show if I uh if he's
forgotten you know my Mi temeritus uh
you know kind of Hosting abilities yeah
I'm gonna be the first
um I was gonna say the first line but I
mean since this is well anyway the first
event public event that I want to be
doing on the book
um is is with gnome in in okay
where and it's going to be a strange
experience because it at least as it's
planned he's going to be my interlocutor
he's going to be asking me questions at
least that's what the plan is and I've
done many things with gnome where it's
worked the other way around so it'll be
intriguing to me to see but if it
doesn't work out that way that's fine
anyway no it's great to be getting back
to Live Events and um live online I
won't be in I won't actually be
physically in London okay now how to
Academy which I've done live many times
but has now moved mostly online I will
but you are doing an event in Vancouver
right I'm doing van Vancouver and I'm
actually doing that'll be the problem
through my Foundation the only events I
do
live in North America I worked through
my foundation in fact if we if we do one
together in San Diego it'll be that way
as well but in England I'm actually
doing two uh at least two live event
public events well one is the hay
festival for a Book Festival and
there'll be a live event in in London
with Richard Dawkins and a few others
and so that'll be nice but I generally
do those only outside of North America
anyway yeah all right great so uh let's
pivot to some questions from my audience
here of which there are many and the
first one has to do with Consciousness
I'm just gonna see if one of my dogs
wants to come in the one who doesn't
okay lady only only uh tribes of Israel
can be admitted into the past yeah yeah
exactly you should be happy to have Levi
come in or maybe but yeah he's
downstairs barking for dinner I think go
on all right okay so Felice super which
uh you know is a name I chose for one of
my kids but was rejected by my wife yeah
he or she asked what are your thoughts
on qualia namely the subjective
conscious experience of the world we
kind of touched upon this but when you
experience the color red or I guess you
don't because you're colorblind or maybe
you don't uh specifically do you believe
it's possible for physics alone to
explain quality
foreign
no I mean no I I know I I think you know
physics isn't necessary part of uh to
explain chemistry and chemistry's
necessary for biology but I think the
The Human Experience is it just like you
know it so
is physics alone going to explain love
well at some very basic level in terms
of understanding the the neurochemical
processes that are electric that are
largely electronic in the brain yeah you
can say it's physics but to understand
the Deep phenomena it's not going to be
very much help
um but qualia is exactly that that
problem of Consciousness that that that
your subjective experience the world
which we all Wonder does everyone seem
the same red as we do when we see red
although as I say I'm colorblind but but
um but and in fact it is an eye-opening
experience that those of you who are not
colorblind should have because this is
one area where you can experience it you
can go look at books where they show the
picture as seen by a person who has
Isn't colorblind and the same picture as
seen by someone who is and when my
friends have seen such things they're
shocked because me they look identical
and they are just shocked about it and
so it's it is one example where you can
get in the head of someone else but that
that
um that
your subjective experience and to
realize is is the hard part is why as I
used to I forget if I said in the book
but I've certainly said it and people
always think I'm joking when I'm on
stage maybe when I've been on stage with
Richard Dawkins I always say I'm a
physicist because it's so easy and it's
so easy compared to you know like
Neuroscience is so hard because it's so
it's a much harder problem but that's
right but what I I talk about in in that
chapter which is I to me fascinating is
one of the things that some
neuroscientists have discovered is how
we even fool ourselves about our
Consciousness we make up stories about
what we think we're seeing or feeling
and why we're doing it that are that we
can prove our our fallacies and and the
split thing experiments that goes on
again and others who uh uh uh have shown
that you know it's really amusing to see
how people will rationalize why they're
doing what they're doing fully thinking
that's the reason why they're doing it
and and so it it's very humbling because
it makes you realize that you know uh uh
well as as a human I think said you know
reason is a slave of passion and it
certainly seems to be
yeah as Einstein said he's not sure
about the universe being infinite but
human stupidity and perhaps that means
bias you know we have a bias towards our
own subjective experiences and so
therefore qualia is uh impossible I just
hate personally you know when you start
off talking about and I I brought this
up with Carl Zimmer when he was on to
discuss Gus life's Edge I actually got
him on the podcast because of an
intemperate you know snarky tweet where
he he tweeted out like you know we don't
we can't even Define life or
Consciousness can you imagine if
astronomers couldn't Define what a
planet is and I'm glad for you to see
that that you believe Pluto as a planet
as I do uh Neil can go you know where on
that front but you know but we love me
yeah I'll have to I'm sorry to interrupt
but you can't also remind me of one of
my favorite quotes from from um Charles
Darwin you probably know this quote at
the end of uh of uh of his famous book
he talks about how Evolution doesn't
relate to the origin of life and it
doesn't answer the question heard his
life he says that he said look and he
says despairingly will so we'll no
sooner know the nature of the origin of
life than what the origin of matter
matter and and you know and and so I I
find that very amusing but I like that
yeah you talk about that in this book
the origin of matter yeah I love these
these you know kind of uh bloopers from
from the past and science but you know
it's too bad because you know Darwin
could have had a good career if he
didn't say that Lawrence if there have
been social media they would have made
fun of him you know anyway same with
Maxwell right okay so let's go back to
something Newton would have never made
it out of uh insane asylum so it's oh
yeah he would have been uh canceled many
times over okay
put away yeah okay so here's a question
that you can answer uh with uh one
sentence probably but Vil ldtz or v d l
z t asks what are your thoughts on The
Logical Universe Grand unified theory
and it's okay to say I have none
on The Logical Universe Grand unified
theory I've never heard of it you know
what that is so so okay let's move on if
my theories are I don't know so my my
answer is yeah I don't have any thoughts
on it because I don't know what it is
um but I expect but I suspect the fact
that I don't know what it is makes me
strongly suspicious of whatever
that's right okay uh user 1990 says is
fusion power achievable or just
pseudoscience well we should say it is
achievable but is it practical and I
want to layer on to that what if chat
GPT you know gets a hold of fusion
reactors I mean are you worried about
the potential for some form of danger to
come from Ai and nuclear fusion in
particular or fission well look let me
answer the second question first um
um uh I was as you know for a dozen
years ahead of the board of sponsors
that both the atomic scientists and and
participated and unveiled the Doomsday
Clock every year and um which was a
great honor uh uh it followed in the
footsteps of actually Oppenheimer and
Einstein we're the first ones who lead
that organization but um uh um
one of the things we were and I'm still
concerned about is if you ask me about
the dangers of AI or at least
machine learning control is the control
of nuclear weapons it already is a hair
trigger and precisely because of this
ridiculous fact that our nuclear weapons
are our remain on hair trigger in spite
of every single president including the
democratic presidents who've all said
they would change that
and and get them and and and take them
off launch on warning status
um uh they haven't and and therefore as
you anyone in fact um
what's his name
great Danielle Ellsberg um
he wrote a great book which is
terrifying
um as did a few other people uh in
command and control is another great
book of talking about all the near
misses where where where where we've
almost had Armageddon because we've come
so close to launching on a warning and
so one can imagine
um the machine a machine learning
algorithm and now
having said that it could be that the
machine learning algorithm is better
than than people at judging whether to
launch on warning or not so who am I to
say but it is it is if you're a human
being and most of us are I know some who
aren't but if you're a human being
um most people kind of intuitively feel
that at least there should be some human
making that decision perhaps not least
because the ultimately it'll be Humanity
that'll be the suffering for it but but
it is an issue it is an issue however as
Fusion is concerned to get to your
listeners question
um yeah
well the answer we used to say that
Fusion is very promising is what Frank
Welch used to say about String Theory
it's very promising and it keeps
promising and promising but um
um
um the the uh it used to be we all say
that 25 years in the future and that's a
time and variant statement and and uh
it's always been 25 years in the future
it'll always be 25 years in the future I
don't think that's the case
um
I don't see it as being
um playing a key practical role in
affecting our uh the uh human energy
production in the in the foreseeable
future
um by foreseeable the near term future
in the time scale which is relevant to
say address climate change
it is also worth pointing out the lie
that was propagated by the of course by
the false media but by all media and by
the organization the department of
energy itself which announced it when
when lost when um Livermore Labs
achieved what was a key goal which is
finally with their laser system
at least producing more energy on the
the palette
more energy came out of the palette that
was in than was it that was received by
that palette
first of all that was not that in any
way a practical system secondly it
wasn't designed
for energy production in the first place
was designed to be able to test nuclear
weapons but there are there is a
technology in the Taco Mac in in France
uh etera system I suspect will get that
breakthrough but it's a 10 billion
dollar system that you know it's so it's
such centralized technology that it I do
think it will it will be able to produce
a fusion reactor potentially even in my
own lifetime at some level but well is
that going to be a game changer no not
in the near term and specifically
because the the technological
requirements are are so great now you
know experimentalists are smart people
and maybe they'll change that but I
suspect we'll need to rely on other
things well before that
yep I agree okay next question
um uh is from HH listener HH what can we
do about Michio Kaku he's clearly out of
control
I shouldn't say what I call them not on
the air anyway okay okay next question
you know if you could do like you can do
to me or you can do it anywhere else you
can just choose to not listen if you
don't want to that's the great thing so
I'm fully
in favor of people being able to spout
nonsense
um and that's a great part of Street
speech because you're free to if you
think they're spending nonsense to
explain why
um and I've done it on stage with me
show it was a Charming Man by the way
yeah oh he is yeah but but uh but I do
think he spots nonsense a lot of the
time and it is unfortunate that people
you know I can say and I've said this
before a long time ago I mean that's the
problem the responsibility of a
scientist and the responsibility of a
scientist who has some public platform
um is great because it's okay to mislead
but not to knowingly mislead we all
mislead unintentionally and I've first
realized that when I wrote my first book
again when you were a baby
um yeah uh and I got people right back
say I love this book because I
understood explained this this and this
and I knew it never I didn't I didn't
touch any of those things but then I
thought well this is motivating that
person to get excited and that's fine
but we shouldn't knowingly mislead and I
and I've and I've on stage age
to hit me show because I believe
sometimes he knowingly misleads and and
has misleaded and and and that's that's
unfortunate he says what people want to
hear and the intention is good because
he's trying his intention is to try and
get people excited by science and I
understand that but I still don't think
that gives us license to to go and we
all tend to do it right go beyond it's
really interesting it's really hard when
you're talking to journalists and they
want to hear something to say Naf you
know it's not the case or it's we think
maybe but it's not they all want to hear
absolutely they don't like to hear
perhaps or with this level of
uncertainty because it's not something a
journalists like to hear and so
scientists are often say things they
really shouldn't because you know they
really want to please the person who
they're talking to unlike me who has no
desire to please you whatsoever
well I want to I want a quote from a
book that was written when you were a
baby uh called the Torah the Old
Testament it says Thou when I was young
yeah okay it says Thou shalt not put a
stumbling block in front of a blind man
and then it ends because I am the Lord
your God now Lawrence you and I study
talmud frequently uh whenever I get you
on the show I can't resist I love
talking Tom McGee would have been what's
called a tomodacham uh like Einstein
would have been reputedly by the god
al-hador the the leader of the
generation of his time said that
Einstein should have been a time but
anyway you could have had a good career
Lawrence but anyway that statement the
statement I am God is very interesting
because
this is the first half of the statement
was good it was second half that seemed
well let me explain why it's just in all
the the reason that it says that it also
says it many other times it says it uh
in another instance it says uh when you
see your enemy and his donkey is
overburdened help him out because I am
the Lord your God now that sounds stupid
you just use reason I think if you're a
place I'm the larger god with reason
which is the right thing to do then I
think you come to the same conclusions
but go on I'm sorry to interrupt but not
exactly okay yeah I know I know it's fun
to do this our banter is you know
legendary when we go on tour this fall
it's going to be really fun but the
reason that it says that is because but
for that statement there's no way a
blind man would know you put a stumbling
block in front of him in other words
it's making a claim that you could do
something like hate your neighbor in
your heart which is another commandment
how would I know that you hate me in
your heart seriously hate me because I
have yeah yeah I mean because
but no no but the point is you could get
away with these things and and the point
is what you just said about Michio and
others is I think apropos of that
statement in other words you should not
knowingly mislead the public because the
public doesn't know so replace god with
science yeah I could just say that I
think it's really high protons are
Little Pink Elephants It's amazing And
if I said it people would you know at
some level you'll sell a lot of books
right you'll sell some books but uh and
you can't be falsified right to them
they do what you want and that would
really sell books okay but go on right
uh so anyway that's the point I think
that's but you're saying yet again the
book The Torah that you are just
obviously so committed to since you
wrote The Greatest Story Ever Told so
far I did all right yeah it was a great
story The Tour was up there but mine
all right Lawrence we've reached the end
of the regularly scheduled broadcast but
I do encourage you to answer one final
question we started the show with Sir
Arthur C Clarke's famous dictum followed
by a live magic show that any
sufficiently advanced technology is in
distinction from Magic Arthur said many
things he also said for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
lastly he said the only way to know the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible that's the name
of my podcast I asked you that question
last time I've and I've started a new
tradition Lauren since you were on last
year and that's to ask a following
statement of good old Sir Arthur the
following statement I want your reaction
too he said when a distinguished but
elderly scientist now I'm not calling
your elderly I know you're retired but
I'm not calling your Elder he said when
it distinguished but elderly scientist
says something is impossible says
something is possible he is very likely
right when he says something is
impossible he is very likely wrong
Lawrence I want to ask you what have you
been wrong about
[Music]
I mean it's hard for me to their
multitude of things every day that I'm
wrong about seriously I I I was I'll
tell you one thing I'll tell you two
things one that's sort of more
physics-wide and one that's related to
yeah to someone you is spending time
with I guess um this one was is I when I
was a junior faculty member at Yale a
distinguished colleague of mine in
astronomy a very distinct astronomer
said
we would never be able to measure the
fundamental constants of of of uh of the
universe like the Hubble constant and
things like that because because
astrophysics would always intervene
every time someone would make a
statement about Omega the density
universe and it would always show me
wrong because you'd find out that there
were loopholes for it and and and and it
seemed to be the case okay and and he
would and and that and so I you know
because he was wise and I thought well
okay I I learned to be of course
skeptical and I still remain skeptical
when people tell me that you know
there's some fundamental contradiction
in the Hubble constant as measured by
the CMB versus Supernova and somehow
that means the crazy things well I
generally my general feeling is that
experiments tend to be wrong a lot of
the time
um and you have to be careful not as
much as theorists yeah I know but
exactly and uh but but anyway so I think
that that you know I certainly changed
my mind about that with it with the I
think many of us and I'd run a meeting
at Yale I taught there about the
cosmomic way background in 89 or just
before Kobe before Colby maybe sometime
around then
um yeah and and it just seemed
impossible that we'd ever be able to
measure the fundamental microwave
background properties of dust and other
things were just getting in the way it
was beautiful if you could that would
never happen dust would never mess up a
CMB experiment Lawrence and and this is
It's a fascinating bit of Sociology if
you don't mind me taking a minute yeah
in your own field which you may have
talked about but
it's hard for people to appreciate this
so the Kobe satellite suddenly for the
first time was able to show amazingly
that there were primordial fluctuations
that weren't that you could disentangle
from from our galaxy and what what is
what is so
remarkable about that is within within
months of course it was realized that
terrestrial experiments had already been
able to see that much of that stuff but
it always assumed that the noise was in
the background you know because they
couldn't control it in the same way that
a satellite could or you know above the
atmosphere and they'd assumed that they
weren't seeing it but within you know
boom boom boom boom all these other
experiments started being able to sit
because it was assumed that you'd never
be able to measure these fun this
fundamental stuff thing and that was a
real that was like the banister effect
the banister effect when Roger Bannister
beat the form in a mile no episode
everybody does I was I was wrong about
that in the sense that I think I assumed
that and in fact I assumed again I've
always underestimated well no I haven't
always but I've I've often under I've
learned not to underestimate the
tenacity and Ingenuity of many
experimental physicists I kind of
thought gravitational waves always find
that they're wasting 30 years of their
life friends of mine working on it
um you know it's great but yeah come on
you're not gonna do it and of course
they do so I've often underestimated
what experimentals could do and I think
it's really important we talk about
quantum computers or other things or
infusion to realize that you know it's
fine to to look at all the problems but
you know but humans are really ingenious
um and then yeah and then more personal
version of it is is you know we you
talked about Jordan Peterson and I I
have to admit I largely dismissed him as
an intellectual or at least as a person
worth talking to uh before I had my
first chat with him on his podcast
where I learned that he was actually
interested in learning about things and
that you know and he still says things
I've actually disagree with every now
and then but but anyone who's at least
interested in asking questions and
learning is someone I have an innate
respect for at some level regardless of
whether I agree with him or disagree
with them I think I mean you know you
talked about Trump I mean I have no
respect for the man for many reasons but
one is it's clear if he has no interest
in learning about anything
yeah the Curiosity factor I think yeah
Jordan uh you know I was a little
nervous to go on his podcast and uh and
I was warned by people you know your
fellow countrymen Gad sad who I know you
know and love and what we all love again
but um you know be careful because he's
gonna talk a lot and he's gonna you know
kind of just don't let him monopolize
the conversation and I didn't find that
at all you know when when I was on the
conversation he I spoke three quarters
in fact so much so Lawrence that I was
planning to have him on my podcast and
then I said well maybe be better because
he has you know these 6K cameras and he
has a crew flying into San Diego maybe
I'll just ask him some questions as if
he's on my podcast and then I don't need
to do a podcast I'll just chop it up and
and I found he was he was just asking me
too much about about dust about the
properties of the electromagnetic
radiation but the plank length and I was
like oh shoot I'm not gonna be able to
ask him questions to make a fake podcast
anyway he agreed to come on the show as
you have your fellow Canadian cameras
when he was with me it was just
something in his house so but you know
but yours has a million views and you
have a million views on that yeah yeah
no it's true but I I I don't and many
people condemn me for this but I don't
try and time who's talking it's an
interesting conversation but that's all
I learned that from past guest Neil
deGrasse Tyson who right before he
called right after he called me a racist
or he said I'm gonna play the race card
on you because I said you know how did
you get to be such a good you know
conversationalist that you you plan on
is it something that you've worked on or
you know were you born with it and he
said you wouldn't ask a white person you
know why there's such a good I was like
I just asked you if you worked on it and
he said no I actually work very hard on
a Time the guest of my uh my host and I
see how many weeks I've known Neil since
since he before he was Neil yeah right
we're used to come no I know pictures he
once told me to see how I did stuff but
yeah Leo more than anyone else and I
admire that in this in some ways admire
this me too concertedly
single-mindedly
directed what became Neil I mean he had
a plan and he any and any conscious plan
for doing exactly what he's done and and
he said on a podcast
and with yeah and sometimes surprisingly
and some people might not like certain
of the ways he's done that but he he
achieved exactly what he wanted to do
and I yeah he thinks about these things
very very deeply yeah yeah he said he
never says something in public that he
hasn't written down which I find very
admirable anyway People Say Never but
anyway we'll see I'm pretty sure exactly
I think he probably talks to his wife
you know and it doesn't write it down
I've forgotten to say things on on
either on stage or or in our podcast
that he hasn't been here very good
Lawrence this has been a lot of fun I'm
going to run to office hours it's been a
wonderful conversation get the book in
all auditions Kindle and print and and
audio where I hear Lawrence's
mellifluous voice Lawrence thank you so
much and tune in to the origins project
podcast donate to the origins foundation
and we'll see you next time in person in
San Diego yeah we'll see in San Diego
and thanks for that nice things you were
about to say about the book when your
camera went down and you and I hope
you're gonna beat them some other time
yeah I'll figure out I look forward to
see being with you live and thank you it
was so it's been a pleasure and I knew
it would be thank you likewise thank you
so much
[Music]